[Zene]
Szia Barni! Üdvözöllek a műsoromban.
Nagyon izgalmas beszélgetés elé nézünk,
ugyanis hoztam egy jó pár témát, amit
szeretnék átbeszélni veled. Szervusz
Szabolcs. Köszöntlek. És azokat is, akik
meg fogják hallgatni ezt a beszélgetést.
Nemrég jártatok pont Rómába. A tervetek
az volt, hogy Carlo Acutisnak a szentély
avatásán pontosabban nem is ez volt a
terv, hanem beterveztétek ezt a
kirándulás, és utána derült ki, hogy
Carlo Akutis szenti avatása lesz pont
arra az időpontra tervezve, és aztán
Ferenc pápa temetése került sajnos erre
az időszakra. Kicsit mesélnél erről az
útról, hogy milyen volt, milyen volt,
hogy ennyiszer változott a forgatókönyv?
Igen, az eredeti tervünk az volt,
hogy a húsvét utáni hetet Rómába
töltsük, azt hisziibe és Rómába a
közösségünk fiataljaival. Ugye húsvét
utani héten terveztük ezt az
arándoklatot, nem kirándulást. A kettő
között az a különbség, hogy amikor
kirándul az ember, akkor tátja a száját,
csodálkozik, nézi, azt mondom, a
felszínt. Az arándok viszont valahogy
mélyebbre akar látni. Az arándok szent
céllal megy, és minden keresztény
hazamegy Rómába. Mi katolikusok
különösképpen is, és ott dobog a az
egyháznak a szíve. És valóban ott volt a
szívünkben ez a vágy, hogy találkozzunk
Ferenc pápával, és ott legyünk Carlo
Akotisznak a szent
javatásán.
És húsvét vasárnapján még láttuk a pápát
a
képernyőkön, akkor bár erőtlen volt már,
csupán az áldás szavait tudta elmondani,
de megáldotta Rómát, mint Róma püspöke
és a világot. Mi másnap készültünk a
Rómába indulni, és akkor jött a
hírhúsvét hétfőn, hogy meghalt a
pápa. De érdekes ez az időszak a
keresztény ember életében. Olyan nagy
húsvétnak az öröme, hogy nem fér meg a
templom falain belül, és nem fér meg egy
napba, hanem a keresztények húsvétot
nyolc napon átünneplik.
És valahogy ebbe olyan ünneprontóan
beköszönt Ferenc pápának a halálla. De
azért szeretnék erről beszélni, mert van
ennek egy érdekes ilyen misztikus
vonása. Azt érzem, hogy Ferenc pápa,
mint sokan nagyok
bár nem törvényszerűség, de megfigyeltem
egy-két dolgot, hogy a nagy emberek a
halálukkal is tanítanak minket. És
ha megnézzük, akkor ki volt az előde
Ferenc pápának? Benedek pápa, 16.
Benedek, és ő december 31-én halt meg,
amikor valami régi véget
érkezdődik el. Ki volt az előde Benedek
pápának? I János Pál, szent I. János
Pál. Mikor halt
meg? Az irgalmasság vasárnapján, a
húsvétot követő vasárnapon, egy olyan
vasárnapon, aminek ő adta ezt a nevet.
Lengyelországból hozva a az irgalmas
Istennek a az üzenetét, és ünnepé tette
ezt a vasárnapot, és pont azon a napon
halt meg. Valami olyat hangsúlyozott ki,
ami fontos a mai ember számára, hogy
Isten nem irgalmatlan. Ő a tékozló
fiúknak az istene, aki megbocsát az
embernek, ha bűnbánatot tart, hazatér.
És akkor így elgondolkodtat engem, ki
volt a legnagyobb székely. Márton Áron.
Boldog emlékű Márton Áron. Mikor halt
meg? Egy küzdelmes élet után, egy nagyon
emberpróbáló
századba, mint Mózes az erdélyi
magyarságnak az élén harcolt az
igazságért, és Szent Mihály arkangyal
ünnepén halt meg. Éppen akkor, amikor a
gyulafehérvári székesegyházba, az ő
templomába búcsúra gyűltek az
emberek. És elhangzott a Jelenések
könyvének az olvasmánya. A Szentírás
utolsó lapjainban, hogy Mihály és
angyalai, vagyis Mihály arkangyal harcol
a sátánnal. És van ott
egy rövid mondat, vagy egy tőmondat, és
győztek, és ő meghalt, harcolt az
igazságtalansággal, a kommunizmussal
szemben. Bár emberileg úgy tűnt, hogy
akkor most elveszett. Mégis győzelem
volt ez. És Ferenc pápa mikor halt meg?
Húsvét vasárnapján még áldást adott.
Aztán húsvét hétfőn meghalt egy kicsit
így ünneprontó módon, ami keresztény
nagy halál fölött aratott győzelmi
ünnepünkbe egy kicsit így vagy az
beárnyékolva.
És nagyon érdekes, amit Rómába
tapasztaltam. Nem a gyász lengte be a
várost, hanem mi egy olyan találkozóra
mentünk, amit amire Ferenc Pápa hívott
meg minket, a tínédzserek találkozójára.
És ő szeretett volna azon a vasárnapon,
amin ott voltunk az irgalmasság
vasárnapján a fiatalok elé egy igazi
példaképet állítani, egy 15 éves korában
meghalt fiút, Carlo Akutiszt, és mindez
egy szempillantás alatt átszerveződött.
De hogy
Rómába olyan szép volt, hogy a fiatalok
nem tudtak csendben maradni mindenhol a
Halleluja, az alleluja hangzott el.
Olyan érdekes ez a az álluja, hogy a
héber szó azt jelenti, egy meghívás.
Dicsőítsük az Urat, dicsérjük az Urat.
És ezt énekelték a fiatalok. Tehát, hogy
igazán húsvéti volt, amikor
megmutatkozott a halál.
a pápa halálával is, de hogy az élet
fölé kerekedett. És én ezt éreztem
Rómában, olyan szép volt még a temetés
napja is, hogy az
élet győzelme volt. A fiatalok
énekeltek, megtapsolták. Valahányszor
Ferenc pápának a neve elhangzott, mert
szerették Ferenc pápát a fiatalok,
hálásak neki. És akkor ti is részt
tudtatok venni a temetési szertartáson.
magán a temetési szertartásom, mivel
hatalmas tömeg volt, Rómában, nem
voltunk ott, de abban az időben Rómában
voltunk. Az ő egy másik templomában,
mert a
római pápának, mint Róma püspökének négy
fontos temploma van. És mi elmentünk egy
másik templomba, nem a Szent Péter
térre, Szent Pás
sírjához a fiatalokkal. Nagyon sok
fiatal volt. Másfél órát álltunk sorba,
hogy bejussunk. a templomba, és ott
imádkoztunk Ferenc pápáért. Azt a napot
úgy így mélyebb
imádságba töltöttük, úgyhogy nem voltunk
ott a temetés szertartásán. Ühüm. És ezt
a fiatalok is akkor így élték meg,
akikkel együtt elindultatok, hogy ez egy
ez ez valójában ez egy ünnep. Valah egy
így furcsa módon egy ünnepé vált ez a ez
a Ferenc pápa halála. Valahogy úgy
voltunk, mint a az egészen kicsi
gyermekek a a temetés alkalmával, ha
családban gyász van, hogy ők ezt még még
nem értik, és nem nem az dominál az
életükben.
Figyelték a felőttek. Nem is igen nem is
volt amúgy ilyen gyászos hangulatunk
nekünk. Ühüm. Hát hogy is lehetett volna
húsvét nyolcadába, amikor tulajdonképpen
a az életet hirdetjük egyáltalán? Nem
szomorúság volt a szívünkben, inkább
hála, hála, hála. Ha most így Ferenc
pápa szolgálatára
visszatekintenénk, akkor te hogyan
jellemeznéd, hogy ő milyen pápa volt, mi
a mi a hagyatéka?
Ferenc pápa nagyon emberközeli pápa
volt. Már az ő
megjelenésével tanított. Talán
emlékszel, és sokan emlékeznek, amikor
megjelent volt a az erkéjen, ismeretlen
volt az arca, de az első szavaival,
amikor azt mondta, hogy vagy jó estét
kívánt a Rómának és a világnak, hogy
belopta a mosolyával magát a
szívünkbe. Ferenc pápa
nagyon érdekes, hogy jezsuitaként a
Ferenc nevet választotta, mert az ő
példaképe Assziszi Szent Ferenc volt.
800 évvel ezelőtt élt Asiszi Ferenc és
egy gazdag családból
származott. A a fiatal
éveiben úgy megpróbálta
őt az élet, és nagyon hamar rájött arra,
hogy nem valami földi célt kell kitűzni.
megismerte Istent, és Istennek az
ismerete eltöltötte örömmel az ő szívét,
és önként döntött arról, hogy lemond a
gazdagságról, mert az akadály lehet a az
életébe, mert az üdvösséget tűzte ki
céljául, és önként vállalta a
szegénységet, az
egyszerűséget. Tulajdonképpen megélte az
evangéliumot. Ferenc pápa számára azt
hiszi szent Ferenc egy példakép volt. És
hát azt láttuk, mint egy mai Szent
Ferenc, vagy mondhatnám úgy, hogy mint
az evangéliumból kilépő 21. századi
Jézus. Ő nagyon hasonlított rá, azon az
úton akarta járni, amit Jézus mutatott
nekünk az egyszerűségbe, a békének a
hangsúlyozásába, az önként vállalt
szegénységébe, a természetnek a
szeretetébe, merthogy a világ nagy
problémáira felhívta
figyelmet. A Laudató szenciklikáját
érdemes elolvasni. hogy ezt a gyönyörű
földet, amit ajándékba kaptunk, mi
tönkretehetjük, felelősek vagyunk ezért
a a földért, a gyönyörű
világunkért. Aztán összehívta a világ
vallási vezetőit, és
azt kérte, hogy imádkozzanak a
békéért. meghívott
egymással ellenséges kapcsolatban álló
testvérnépeket, a vezetőiket. Meghívta
Rómába, például egy afrikai népeknek a
vezetőit, és
arra bátorította őket, kérjenek
bocsánatot.
És van egy olyan megható pillanat,
amikor letérdel és megcsókolja a
lábukat,
tiltakoznak, de ő ezzel jelét adta
annak, hogy ilyen alázatosnak kell lenni
a
kiengesztelődéshez. Na, összefoglalva
Ferenc pápa arra tanított minket,
papokat, hogy legyünk bárányszagú
pásztorok.
A keresztényeknek pedig azt mondta, hogy
lépjenek ki a templom falai közül. És ő
ezt élte, és különösen szeretett minket
magyarokat. Több mint 50 országot
látogatott meg, de a magyar népet
háromszor is
meglátogatta. Járt Magyarországon, az
eukarisztikus
kongresszuson, járt Erdélybe. És milyen
gondviselésszerű.
Érdemes ezen egy kicsit eltöprengeni,
hogy
a mi városunkon is autóval,
személyautóval járt és áldást adott,
integetett, imádkozott. Ott volt
Csíksomjon, ami elképzelhetetlen volt
számunkra, mert akkora
nemzetek, katolikus nemzetek vannak a
világon, akikhez nem jutott el a pápa,
vagy legalábbis a ő személyesen, és
hozzánk eljött ide, és aztán még egyszer
visszatért Magyarországra, mert kedveli,
kedvelte ezt a az országot. Úgyhogy
különösen megajándékozottak vagyunk. Ö
azt gondolom, hogy ő belopta a szívünkbe
és a a magyar népnek a szívébe magát. És
az új pápáról mit lehet tudni? Te
ismerted előtte őt? A a nevét hallottam,
de keveset tudtam róla. Ugyanúgy voltam,
mint Ferenc pápal. De már az első
megjelenésével is egy pár nap telt el
tulajdonképpen az ő
pápaságából. Azt látom, hogy Ferenc
pápának a nyomdokaiba lép, az
ő művének a a folytatója lesz. Nagyon
kedves ember, dinamikus ember, fiatalos,
ahogy én látom, és erre szükség van ma.
Aztán különleges érzékenysége van a
szegények iránt, a szociális problémák
iránt, mert lelki pásztor volt,
misszióban volt, amerikai születésű, de
hogy bevándorló családnak a sarja, és
ezért nemcsak
az amerikai mentalitást ismeri, és annak
a hordozója, hanem misszióban volt,
Perú. Ott nagyon szerették. Van egy
osztálytársam, vagy volt egy
osztálytársam Rómában, aki éppen abban a
az egyház megyében
működik, ahol ő püspök volt, és
nagyon-nagyon szerették. Igazán olyan
volt, mint amiről Ferenc pápa beszél,
hogy bárányszagú
pásztor és
szerzetes. Ez is egy fontos dolog.
Ferenc pápa is szerzetes volt. A
szerzetesek valahogy
érzékenyebbek a
közösségiségre, ami nagyon fontos a egy
vezető, egy egy vallási vezetőnek a
személyébe, hogy meglejön vagy a a
vonásaiban meglegyen, merthogy nem egyes
számba gondolkodik, hanem többes számba.
az életét a szerzetesnek, az imádság, a
az alázatosság, az önként vállalt
szegénység határozza meg. És az új
pápánk szintén azt gondolom, hogy ebbe
fog példakép lenni számunkra.
Amúgy azt lehet tudni számomra mindig
olyan misztikus az, ami ami a bíborosok
elzárkóznak és valami rejtélyes dolog
történik, többször szavaznak, néha a
fekete füst száll fel, néha van olyan
is, hogy elhúzódik és egy egy-két nap
múlva lesz egy fehér füst. Hogy hogy ott
mi történik? Ilyenkor van valamilyen
belső információ, ami eljut hozzád, hogy
hogy ilyenkor ilyen belső politikai
harcok folynak, vagy mindenki elvonul és
imádkozik, és utána visszajönnek és
szavaznak? Vagy hogy kell elképzeljem,
hogy hogyan történik ez a választás?
Nagyon kíváncsi volt a világ, mert
minden titkot meg akart fejteni a világ,
de hogy milyen szép, hogy 2000 éves
múltja van ennek és külön forgató könyve
van a pápa választásnak, és ami titok,
azt ne akarjuk mi
feltörni. Az tény, hogy imádságban
vannak együtt. Egy liturgiája van a
konklávénak, imádsággal kezdődik és
végig meghatározza az imádság. ben
emberek
beszélgetnek és
olyan emberek, akik nagy felelősséget
hordoznak, nemzetek egyházainak a
vezetői, és hogy
közöttük jelen van a a szabadabban
gondolkodó, és jelen van a
hagyományokhoz ragaszkodó, mondhatjuk
úgy, hogy a konzervatívabb mentalitás
is, és biztos bizonyosan ütköztetik.
Tény az, hogy
Benn aki bemegy oda abba a terembe,
mindenki érzi a felelősségét annak, hogy
milyen nagy dolog ez, hogy
megtalálják a legalkalmasabb embert. És
a legfontosabb szempont szerintem az,
hogy ma a jelenlegi
helyzetben ki az, aki a legjobb választ
tudja adni, a legfrissebb, a
legevangéliumibb választ tudja ezekre a
kérdésekre adni. és tökéletes ember
nincsen. Éppen ezért meg vagyok
győződve, hogy
senki nem
akar pápa lenni, hanem a testvérek
választják meg. És mivel
felelősségteljes
emberek ezek, akkor ha a többség jónak
tartja őket, akkor igent mondnak,
vállalkoznak a
szolgálatra, hogy rátegyék az
életüket.
És hogy én nem is akarom tudni
hogy benne milyen beszélgetések voltak.
Én azt gondolom, hogy nem is tartozik a
gyermekekre az, amikor a felnőttek arról
beszélnek, hogy akkor milyen elvek
szerint fogják a következő nagy
döntéseket meghozni. Ebbe tényleg van
egy ilyen bölcsesség, amit amit mondasz.
Neked annyira a kíváncsiság azért mégis
csak hajt engem, de az az, amit mondtál,
hogy senki sem akar pápa lenni, én én
tényleg el tudom képzelni, hogy hogy egy
bíborosnak az élete azért nem annyira
nyilvános. Nyilván, hogy az egy az egy
magas pozíció a bíboros, de hirtelen
amikor pápává válsz, az egész világ rád
tekintés folyamatosan a hátralevő
életednek szinte minden egyes szegletét
nézni fogja, és akár kritizálni is.
Úgyhogy úgyhogy én, én azt hiszem, hogy
ez nem egy akkora előny pápának lenni,
hogy valaki arról álmodjon, milyen jó én
pápa szeretnék lenni. Lehet, hogy több
hátránya van ennek mint akár előnye.
Komoly
felelősségteljes szolgálat.
Ez a földi életét követeli minden
óráját, minden
napját. De olyan szép az, hogy a
testvérek mögötte állnak, a bíborosi
testület imádkoznak érte, hogy számíthat
rájuk. Ezt is kérte a szent atyám. Olyan
szép volt a az ő első
felhívása, a békére, a
köszöntése. Azzal köszönt be, mint a
feltámadt Úr Jézus. Békesség nektek. Hát
erre van szüksége a világnak most. Igen.
És és rengeteg kihívás elé fog nézni.
14. Leó páápa, miért választotta ezt a
nevet? Ezt tudod?
Igen, hát most már néhány gondolattal
meg is magyarázta ezt nagy elődeihez és
a közvetlen elődéhez, vagy a névben
elődéhez, 13. Leó pápához köthető ez,
aki az 1900-as évek elején volt pápa, és
a kornagy
kihívásaira választ adott, és ő is
szeretne. 14. Leo pápánk is szeretne a
kor kívásaira
megfelelő választ adni. Ezért már meg is
említette a mesterséges intelligenciát
például. De hát ez még várat magára.
Imádkozzunk érte. Rendben. Egy kicsit
beszélgessünk Carlo Akutisról. A
közösségben a fiataloknál elkezdtük
észrevenni, hogy valamiért nagyon
népszerűvé vált Carlo Akutis. Tehát
nyilván valamiér ezt ezt ezt akarom
megfejteni. Ő nem az én korosztályom, és
nem az a a hozzám tényleg nem an nem áll
annyira közel, mint a fiatalokhoz, de ez
az igazi őszinte lelkesedés, ez ez
elcsodálkoztatott engem. Kicsit mesélj
először is Carla Cuttisról, hogy ő ki
volt, és utána térjünk rá arra, hogy
miért lehet népszerű.
Egy olasz srác volt, aki 15 éves korában
halt meg 2006-ban.
egy gazdag családból származott, egy
milánói
családból, de számára is ez nagyon
érdekes példakép volt a Sziszi Szent
Ferenc megkedvelte Asszisit, és nem is
csoda, hogy sok időt töltött ott és azt
kérte
az élete utolsó napjában, hogy
odatemessék el. Úgyhogy ma sziszibe van
az ő sírja.
Miért miért olyan különleges a fiatalok
számára? Mindig szükségünk van
példaképekre, a fiatalokonak különösen
is. És egészen fris.
Hát 2006, hogy mondjam, igen. A
napjainknak a a szentje ő, aki
már ismerte a mobiltelefont, az
internetet és használta.
És nagyon érdekes, hogy bár egészen
fiatal volt, de bölcsen tudta használni
ezeket az eszközöket, felfedezte azt,
hogy az internetet lehet az evangélium
terjesztésére használni.
nagy
csodálója volt a az
eukarisztiának, vagy imádója, mondhatjuk
így, merthogy az
eukarisztiába Isten van jelen.
Ezért ez a ez a szó, amit sokszor
helytelenül használunk, mi a magyar
nyelvben, Istennek van fenntartva, az
imádom. És ő az eukarisztikus csodáknak
a helyszíneit kereste fel. A történelem
folyamán többször volt olyan eset,
amikor a megtört kenyérbe, a szent
ostjába különleges módon is
megmutatkozott
asten jelenléte, például a borból
valóban vér lett szemmel láthatóan is,
vagy a szent ostja húsá alakult, és
ezeket a helyeket kereste fel a
szüleivel, dokumentálta.
és egy honlapot hozott létre, kiállítást
is hozott létre, ilyen
vándorkiállítást, hogy az embereknek a
figyelmét visszaterelje a lényegre az
eukarisztiára, hogy vannak
csodák, hogy Isten így is üzen az
embernek. Aztán nagyon szerette a
videójátékokat, de az édesanyja írt egy
nagyon szép könyvet ról a fiam
titka, és abba olvastam,
hogy meghatározta az időt, amennyit
videójátékozik, és befejezte, letette
azt, amit olyan nehéz ma megtenni egy
fiatalnak és az idősebbeknek is,
mennyire használjuk a a telefont, a az
internetet, és ő ezt meg tudta lépni,
ezért lehet példakép, de első áldozása
után
naponta eljárt
szentmisére, gazdag családból származott
és önként szegénységet vállalt, például
titakozott az ellen, hogy több cipője
legyen. Arra kérte a szüleit, hogy
inkább egy szegényt segítsenek, és
naponta segítette a szegényeket. Na hát
ilyen szempontból a fiatalok számára is
valami olyant tett, ami követő, ami egy
kicsit a lécet
fönnep teszi és meghívja fiatalokat egy
értelmesebb életnek a megélésére. Vannak
szép mondatai, neki, mondásai, például
az eukarisztiával kapcsolatosan, hogy az
én utam a
mennyországba, autópályám a
mennyországba, az oltári szentsége, az
eukarisztia, vagy egy nagyon szép
játékos, egészen rövid olasz mondat,
amit sokszor ismételt, hogy nonio madio,
vagyis nem én, hanem
Isten. Valami történt, valamiért
hálálkodnak, ne nekem,
Istennek. És
aztán
a még még egy érdekes mondat eszembe
jut. Azt mondja, hogy mindenki
különlegesnek születik, vagy egyedinek
születik, mégis fénymásolatként hal meg.
Én örvendek, hogy én nem fénymásolként
halok meg. Mondta halála előtt.
Vagyis, hogy Isten
mindenkit egyedinek
teremtett, különleges adottságokat
adott, hogy ne majmoljunk másokat, ne
olyanok akarjunk lenni, mint mások,
hanem olyanok, amilyen amilyenek
lehetünk a legjobbak, amik lehetünk a jó
Istennek a az elképzelése szerint. Igen,
ezt ezt amúgy én is tapasztalom, hogy
ahogy az ember fejlődik, és tényleg a
határait súrolva abba az irányba indul
el, ami az ő elhívása lehet, egyre
színesebb, egyre izgalmasabbá válik az a
személy. És ha viszont abbahagyja a
fejlődést, hogy tegyük fel visszafele
fejlődik vagy stagnál, akkor egyre
inkább ugye ahogy mondta Carlo is, hogy
hogy egymás fénymásolatai leszünk, mi
egyre inkább hasonlítunk egymásra.
Úgyhogy ez ez egy érdekes gondolat. Még
arra akartam rákérdezni, hogy te a
szenti avatási szertartásra, hát nem
hogy készültél, mert tudom, hogy amikor
elterveztitek ezt az utat, ezt az
arándokutat, akkor még nem lehetett
tudni, hogy hogy szenti fogják
avatni Carlo Akutiszt, de de végül is
így esett. Tehát a boldog Carlo
Akutisról akarlak egy kicsit kérdezni,
hogy mit jelent az, hogy boldog valaki,
és hogy hogy kapja meg valaki ezt a
címet, és egyáltalán miért is létezik ez
a szent és ez a boldog cím? Ez ez ez ez
egy ez egy ilyen katolikus specifikus
dolog. Minden idők emberének szüksége
van
példaképekre, és a keresztények a
hitvalló előttük járó keresztényekre
mindig feltekintettek.
Nem imádjuk a szenteket, hanem
tiszteljük őket. Itt fontos
kijavítani azokat, akik azt tanítják,
hogy a katolikusok imádják a szenteket.
Ez azért, mert az imádata az Istennek
van fenntartva, és a egyedül Istent
imádjuk. Ez ez érvényes Máriára is. A
szentek között az első az Úr Jézus
édesanyja Mária. Mi Máriát tiszteljük és
a szenteket is. Ők valamilyen
valamennyien olyanok akarnak lenni, mint
a Hold, akiknek nincsen saját fénye,
hanem visszatűkrözik a nap fényét. Isten
a nap, mondhatjuk így
jelképesen. És a szentek pedig a mi
éjszakánkba ragyogó holdak és csillagok.
És akkor visszatérve a boldoggá szent
avatásra, a az ember a halála
pillanatába,
vagy felbomlik az a az az egység, ami
megvolt, amíg élt. A test az a földbe
kerül,
eltemetik. A lélek viszont él tovább. És
ezt minden ember
aki keresztény, hiszi, hogy a lélek él
tovább. Hová lesz a
lélek? A mi hitünk szerint Isten
közelségébe kerül.
És a katolikus egyház már 2000 éve
egyesekről ezt igazságként ki is
jelenti, hogy ott van Isten
közelébe. És ezek a szentek. De mivel
egy jogi eljárás a szentavatás, mertogy
nem csak azok a szentek, nem csak azok
vannak Isten jelenlétében, akiről
kimondták. Valószínű, hogy hogy ott
vannak a mi őseink közül is sokan. az
életszentség útján járó emberek. Én
hiszem, hogy az én nagymamám is, aki egy
jó imádkozó asszony volt, életszentség
útjá, hogy ott van Istennél, de nem
indítottuk el a szentév avatásnak a
folyamatát.
És akiknek a a szentivatását elindítják,
akkor mondhatjuk azt, hogy ilyen két
lépcsős módon fogja az egyház őket
megvizsgálni, hogy jogos-e ez a kérés.
Először boldog-e, aztán szenté avatni.
Ha az ő
közbenjárásukra történik csoda, ahogy
Carlo esetében is, akkor a a csoda
például egy gyógyulás.
Valakiről az orvosok kijelentik, több
orvos megvizsgálja és kijelenti, hogy
gyógyíthatatlan beteg, hogy itt látszik
a
vég. Kérik a
közbenjárását a
szentnek, és emberileg
megmagyarázhatatlan, hogy teljesen
meggyógyul. Ilyen csodák történtek
Kárlónak a közbenjárására is. Tehát a
csodát Isten teszi, de a szent
közbenjárat, mert Isten közelében van.
És ilyen csodák történnek. Ha
megtörténik ez a csoda, vagy legalább
egy csoda, akkor az egyház szenté avatja
az
illetőt. Beállítja a példaképeknek a
sorába. És olyan szép, hogy
kereszteléskor nemcsak keresztszülőt
választunk.
meghívják a szülők az ő
barátaikat, és az a szép, hogyha a
keresztény életbe példaképeket hívnak
meg, hogy legyenek keresztszülők. De nem
csak a földön keresünk támaszokat, hanem
hogy mondjam, belekapaszkodunk az
égiekbe is, és választanak
védőszentet. Ezért a keresztségbe
valamennyien védőszentet kapunk.
A
bérmáláskor a fiatal ő maga válasz már
nem a szülők, hanem ő egy olyan szentet,
aki számára példakép. És a püspök,
amikor
megbérmál, nem a te polgári neveden fog
szólítani, hanem az új néven, a szentnek
a a nevén fog szólítani és fog
megbérmálni téged. A szerzetesek, amikor
fogadalmat tesznek, vagy belépnek egy
rendbe, akkor választhatnak maguknak új
nevet, és általában egy olyan szentnek a
nevét választják, akik példakép
számukra. Hát így a szentek így lebegnek
előttünk, mint követendő példák. És én
azt gondolom, hogy szurkolnak nekünk a
mennyországból, mint ahogy egy
futballcsapatnak a rajongók, hogy itt a
földön sikerüljön nekünk
győzedelmeskedni a mi harcainkba,
rúgjunk kolokat az ördög kapujába. Hm.
ami számomra is egy kicsit tehát amit a
fejemben helyére kell rakjak, de viszont
tudom, hogy az egyik kritikának a
forrása a katolikus egyházzal szemben
ezek az erekék, hogy ilyenkor a szenti
avatott személynek a testéből vagy a
ruházatából, vagy valamilyen más
használati tárgyából erekék válnak, és
ezekkel
néha kereskednek, meg lehet vásárolni
őket, meg lehet találni itt-ott a
lakásokban
És
és gyanítom, hogy azért sokan elvétik
ezt a határt, hogy nem tisztelik. Habár
kérdés, ez ez is egy kérdés, hogy miért
kell tisztelni egy gyerekét.
Viszont imádkoznak, vagy imádják azt a
tárgyat, és és nem vagyok benne biztos,
hogy
hogy ez miért történik. Egy kicsit ebbe
felvilágosítanál engem?
Amikor Rómába jártunk, az első útunk a
római
falakon, Róma falain kívül a temetkezési
helyekre vezetett a katakombákba. Ez
föld alatti temetkezési helyek, ahol a
keresztények az üldöztetés idején
menekültek, és ott a vértanúk sírja
fölött szentmiséket mutattak be,
összegyűltek, imádkoztak a keresztények,
nem imádták a szenteket.
De mivel számukra példaképek voltak,
ezért igyekeztek a személyes
tárgyaikat, például a ruhát, amibe
vértanú lett, vagy később,
amiután már a földi
maradványok elporlattak egy-egy csont
darabot magukkal vinni, hogy mindegy
emlékeztessék őket mindig arra, hogy
ezek jelesre vizsgáztak ezek a szent
mentek a hitnek a
gyakorlásába, és nem imádták az
ereklyéket a a keresztények,
csupán
tisztelték. És ez a helyes magatartás,
egyedül Istent imádjuk, az
eukarisztiát a kenyérben, az
átváltoztatott szentyában jelenlevő Úr
Jézust imádjuk, az erekéket tiszteljük.
És ha például megcsókolunk is egy
erekjét, akkor is a tiszteletünket
fejezzük ki. Úgy, mint amikor egy ember
a pénztárcájába, vagy éppen a
telefonjának a képernyőjén
mind ott hordozza a gyermekeinek a
képét, a számára kedves személyekét, és
néha amikor hiányoznak, akkor
megpuszilja a képet. Ezt a puszit
tulajdonképpen annak a szeretets
személynek küldi, és nem a telefonnak.
És nem a telefonnak. Igen, így van. És
visszatérve, hogy 2000 év örökségét
hordozzuk a hátunkon mi katolikusok, a
esztendőben voltak az erekékkel
kapcsolatosan a tévedések,
elhajlások, melyik családba, hogyha
visszatekintünk, nincsenek emberi
gyengeségek, nem mutatkozik meg egy
függőségbe, egy öngyilkosságba. valami
valami
tragédiába a családba, a múltba ezek és
valahogy tévedések volt történtek a
történelmünk folyamán, de hogy helyére
kell rakjuk a a dolgokat. Ö ma
akejéket nem pénzért
árulják. Kifejezetten tiltott az
erekéket
pénzér adni. Sőt a az erekét mindig a
püspökökön keresztül kell kérni a
területileg illetékes püspöktől.
Tehát például
Carlo Ákutisznak a az erekjéit, majd az
ő
püspöke adhatja a mi püspökünknek, és
rajta keresztül kaphatjuk meg mi a a
erekjéket, és soha nem szabad azért
pénzt kérni. Én azt gondolom, hogy nincs
ma eltúlozva a keresztény katolikusok
körébe az erekéknek a tisztelete. De hát
hordozzuk a régi időknek a hozzáállását,
a mentalitását is, és közel vagyunk
például a keleti keresztényekhez,
ortodox testvéreinkhez, ahol ez ma
hangsúlyosabb egy kicsit, mint nálunk az
erekéknek a a tisztelete.
Vagyis, hogy
mindig Istennek a a az elsőséget
megadva, az imádat megadva helyezhetjük
csak az
ereklyéket rámutató jelként a a
keresztények elé.
Igen. Most így ahogy beszélgetünk, az
merült fel bennem, hogy van ez a nagy öt
személyiségtípus, és ott tanultam meg,
hogy vannak olyan személyek, akik akik
inkább hajlamosak az absztrakciók fele
vonzódni, és inkább hajlamosak mások,
viszont a praktikus dolgok fele
vonzódni. Ezt külön meg kellett
tanuljam, mert én ahogy egy
intellektuális személy vagyok, szeretem
az absztrakciókat, szeretem a
gondolatokat, és hogy nekem igazi örömet
okoz, hogyha valami valamit megértek,
valami a helyére kerül, valahogy úgy
belekattan. Viszont van egy például
egy-egy munkatársam, aki aki
meghallgatja az én csodálatos
gondolataimat, és akkor utána azt
mondja, hogy oké, és ennek mi a
praktikus hozadéka? Úgy nem nagyon tudom
elképzelni, addig nem is tudok
lelkesedni, ameddig nem látom konkrétan.
És olyankor úgy el kellett gondolkozzak
azon, hogy tényleg másak vagyunk, és
bizonyos embereknek szüksége van arra,
hogy praktikusan ezt hogyan lehet
használni. Nagyon konkrétan kimondva, én
hiába mondok egy absztrakt elvet neki
el, mert ő meghúzza a válát és és nem
érti. És ezt egyre többször tapasztalom
úgy a munkatársaim között, mint a a
környezetemben, hogy ha valamit nem
tudok átadni, ami engem lelkesít, az
inkább rólam szól. Tehát én nem tudtam
edig praktikusan megfogalmazni. Na most
visszatérve a szentekhez és visszatérve
az erekékhez, az egyik gondolatom ezzel
kapcsolatban az, hogy a szent az egy
sokkal praktikusabb manifesztációja
Jézusnak, mert mert olvassuk az
evangéliumba Jézus cselekedeteit, a
tanításait, de de ameddig még Jézus sem
jött el, addig addig Isten egy forma
nélküli
csendes hang volt bennünk, aki vezetett
és történeteket hallottunk róla, de
távoli nak érezhettük. És Jézus már egy
konkrét példa sok, de de még mindig 2000
évvel ezelőtt
történt. Úgyhogy a szentek azok még
konkrétabb példák, és az erekék pedig
kézzel fogható konkrét példák. És így
egy ilyen láncolatként tényleg Istenre
mutat mindenki, mert valójában az erekék
a szentre mutatnak. A szent egyértelműen
Jézusra mutat, Jézus pedig egyértelműen
az Atyára mutat. és hogy hogy
gyakorlatilag valami ilyesmi lehet, nem
ebbe a láncolatba, hogy azért tiszteljük
ezeket az erekéket, mert a figyelmünk
figyelmünket a praktikusról egészen az
absztraktra irányítja. Nagyon szépen
megfogalmaztad ezt. Elfelejtettem azt
mondani az erekjékkel kapcsolatosan,
hogy vannak elsődleges ereklyék, vagyis
amikor a földi
maradványaiból a a szentnek egy
darabkát, Szent István királyunknak a
jobb keze, vagy voltunk Pádoában, Szent
Antalnak a nyelve, a hangképző szervei
éppen maradtak, miután felnyitották a
sírt, és ezt egy zárt üvegedénybe
helyezték el. Persze, amit egy díszes
aranyozott erekje tartóba tettek,
megőriztek, hogy későbbi századoknak a
keresztényei is
majd előtte megállhassanak és
hálálkodhassanak.
És egyes szenteknek megmarad a teste.
Carlo Akutisznak a testét üvkoposóba
őrzik.
Bár egy viasz maszk van az arcán, de a
teste nagy része épp maradt. Ez azért
megérintő egy fiatal számára is ott
látni egy 10 évest a
koporsóba, de olyan
sokakat
elgondolkodtat, olyan sokaknak a
elindítja az olyan sokakat elindít az
élet szentségre, hogy én is tudnék ezen
az úton járni. Az elsődleges erekjék
tehát valami a
testükből megmaradt rész, ami egy erekje
tartóba, egy zárt kicsi
edénykébe van eltéve. Aztán vannak a
másodlagos erekjék, a személyes tárgyak
ezek. Például Carol Akutisnak az
édesanyjával
találkoztunk, azt hiszi be, ez egy
meglepetés volt, és egyik templom előtt
a fiatalok összefutottak vele, és egy
másodlagos erekét adott nekik. Olyan
szép volt, ahogy angolul elbeszélgetett
velük, és azt mondta,
hogy legyetek ti is szentek. Nagyon
megérintette a fiatalokat. Az én fiamnak
sikerült. Legyetek ti is azok.
Hm. Ez ez amúgy tényleg megdöbbentő.
Most így belegondoltam, hogy Carlo most
36 éves lenne, ugye? Vagy körülbelül
2006 halt meg 15 évesen. Számolja ki
mindenki. 15 éves. Izé számolja ki
mindenki magának. Hát az 19 éve volt,
úgyhogy úgyhogy akkor most 34 éves
lenne. Igen. És és tényleg azt látom,
hogy hogy a ezeket a fiatalokat itt a a
mi plébániánkon tényleg megérintette.
volt ez a kezdeményezés, vagyis van ez a
kezdeményezés, a fókuszpont, amit tavaly
először szerveztünk meg, és a szervezés
közben engem tehát nem nem tudom, hogy
ez egy tudatos valami volt, vagy mire
becsöppentem a szervezésbe, azt vettem
észre, hogy újra és újra Carlónak a neve
jön fel, és tényleg azt láttam, hogy
valamiért a szívükön hordozzák a
fiatalok spontánul, úgyhogy, úgyhogy
tényleg tényleg elérte ezt a a célját.
hogy hogy példaképként tudjuk állítani a
tínédzserek elé Carlónak a a
példáját. És azért is jött fel, mert a
fókuszpont ez pont
egy talán fordítsuk meg a
kérdést. Az a fókuszpontnak az ötlete a
te szívedben fogalmazódott meg. egy
kicsit kezdjük abból az irányból, hogy
mi is ez a fókuszpont, és hogy hogyan
fogalmazódott meg, és akkor ezt így
össze fogjuk tudni kötni egy egészé,
hogy hogyan kapcsolódik hozzá Carlo
Akutis is. Én Székudvárhelyen
születtem,
és szép emlékem az, amikor a kommunizmus
bukása után először a
közösséggel kijöhettünk a város
főterére.
Ez 90-ben volt. Két ünnepet a város
főterén ültünk meg mi
katolikusok. Az egyik a szent este volt,
az éjféli mise. Csodálatos volt, ahogy a
patkó a Mártonáron tért, tele volt
keresztényekkel.
és hogy egyáltalán a templomból
kiléptünk a szabadég alatt sokszor
nagyon hidegbe mutattuk be ezt a
szentmisét.
Aztán egy másik alkalom az
a az Úrnapja
volt, amikor kijöttünk a városnak a
főterére, és ekkor zászlóajakkal
érkeztek a környékbeli falvakból, és
szinte kicsinek bizonyult a a főtér.
Olyan sokan voltunk, énekeltünk,
imádkoztunk, és mindkét ünnepnek a
középpontjába, az oltári szentségben, az
eukarisztiában jelenlevő Úr Jézus állt.
Nem más, nem ember, mert ezt a fő teret
megtöltöttük nemzeti ünnepeken
is. Szép volt az is, helye van annak is.
De
én, ha visszatekint a múltra,
Udvarhelyen körülbelül 700 éves múltja
van a katolikus
egyháznak, és abból egy kicsi részt
látok, egy szeletecskét, az elmúlt 35
esztendőt. Ha
visszatekintek az Úr napjára 360 éves
története van, egy tizedét látom az
elmúlt
esztendőt. És azt vettem észre, hogy
ebbe az utolsó
évekbe egy kicsit mintogyha
megfogyatkozott volna a híveknek a a
létszáma.
Persze azt is tudni kell, hogy
valamikor a
forradalomkor a egy plébánia volt
székeudvarán, a Szent Miklós
plébánia, azóta más kisebb plébániák is
létesültek. És
de hogy ez nem nem ezzel magyarázható
az, hogy kevesebben vagyunk hitvalló,
vagy az ünnepet fontosnak tartó
keresztények és katolikusok.
És akkor így Isten elé vittem ezt az
ügyet, mert azt láttam,
hogy Úr napján hiányoznak a fiatalok.
Bár Úr napja egy csütörtöki nap. Iskola
van, egy iskolavárosban vagyunk, és hogy
felekezetileg összetett
udvarhely, nem csak katolikusok vagyunk,
és ez kifejezetten katolikus ünnep, de
hogy mintogyha hiányozna az ifjúság.
Én azt tapasztaltam, 11 évig voltam
ifjúsági lelkész, Erdély ifjúságáért
feleltem, hogy mégis fontos számukra az
eukarisztia, de talán nekünk nem sikerül
ez ezen az ünnepen jól megszólítani
őket, valami feladatot adni nekik, vagy
hogy
valahogy őket is meghallgatni
a
fiatalokat, hogy hogyan lehetne úgy
ünnepelni az eukarisztiá ában köztünk
levő
Istent, hogy az a ti számotokra is
kedves
legyen. És akkor azt érzem, hogy persze
mögötte van egy ilyen tapasztalat is,
hogy Budapesten rendezték meg a
Nemzetközi Eukarisztikus Kongresszust
évekkel ezelőtt, és hogy az olyan szép
volt. Voltak előkészítő alkalmak
ahol egybe hívták a fiatalokat. Na,
lényeg az,
hogy megszületett bennem egy gondolat,
egy
imaest, ahol ami ráhangol az ünnepre, és
ahol a az eukarisztia legyen a
középpontbal, de sok ének legyen, és
tanúságtétel a fiataloknak a tanúságtét.
Ők mondják el, hogy mit jelent számukra
a szentmise és benne az oltári szentség.
És akkor így született meg a fókuszpont,
aminek a neve is beszédes. Ugye együtt
találtuk meg ezt a nevet. Mi tudjuk, mit
jelent, mert valamennyien használunk
telefont és kamerát, és néha homályos a
kép, akkor mit kell tenni? Élesíteni,
ráfókuszálni a lényegre. És így nagyon
szép nevet találtunk, mert vissza kell
találnunk, be kell élesítenünk az egész
lényünket a középpontra, a az Úr
Jézusra, mert a amikor a fiataloknak
tanítok az egyházról, több szempontból
szoktam megvilágítani, hogy mit is
jelent egyház, akkor beszélek a plébánia
közösségről is. És akkor szoktam
használni egy jelképet, egy képet,
hogyha egy hagymát középen ketté vágunk
derékba, akkor különböző körök
mutatkoznak meg rajta. Középen van az
életnek a sarja, a székje, hogy lehet
még másképp fogalmazni, ahonnan kihajt
majd a
hagyma, és körülötte a különböző körök,
és így van a mi közösségeinknek a
középpontjában, vagy így kellene legyen
az eukarisztia, a szentségi élet, a
Jézus körül való forgás, ahol ketten
vagy hárman össze Összegyűltök az én
nevembe, ott vagyok, mondta Jézus. És
valóban, ahol az ő nevébe gyűlnek össze,
ott van egy középpont, de egy plébánia
emberekből áll, és különb különböző
hozzáállással, vagy hogy mondjam,
vonzással, távolsággal az Úr Jézustól, a
szentségi élettől. Van akinek
mindennapi kenyere az eukarisztia, aki
nem tud nélküle élni, mert vizet lehet
inni minden nap frisset is, ha forráshoz
mész, elöntöd a a tegnapi
megmaradt vizet és friss
vizetőltesz. Lehet inni egy hetes vizet
is, és lehet inni több hónapos vizet is.
És így vannak keresztények, különböző
körök. Van, aki számára vasárnapi
szentmise fontos, de mindennapi
találkozás nincs meg az Úr Jézussal.
Aztán van, akiknek az ünnepe fontos, és
egyre nagyobb ez a kör. végén a
közömbösöknek a nagy gyűrűje, rétege,
akiket hordozunk a hátunkon, mint
közösség, mert
ők csak papíron a
keresztények, mert az életükben nem
mutatkozik meg személyes találkozás az
Úr Jézussal. Na és így ha egy
közösségnek az életéből a középpontot
kivesszük, és azért a két évezred
alatt voltak olyan kezdeményezések,
vannak olyan példák, amikor a középpont
elveszett, akkor egy nagyon jó emberi
szervezet, egy humanista társaság
lehetünk, kiváló embereknek a jól
szervezett társasága, de nem egyház. Az
egyháznak a középpontjában ott kell
legyen az eukarisztia, az Úr Jézus. És
ezért vagyok hálás a fókuszpontért,
amikor a városunknak a
szívébe, nem a templom falai között,
hanem onnan
kilépve az eukarisztia a középpontba
kerül. És a fiatalok számára is olyan
kedves volt ez a az ünnep, amit az idén
is szeretnénk megszervezni, mégpedig Úr
napjának az előéjén, hogy hangolja fel a
szívünket a másnapi ünnepre, mindegy,
meghívva őket a szentmisére is. És ezen
az alkalmon majd vendégünk lesz Budapest
egyik nagyon kedves
püspöke, Fabri Cornél fiatal püspök és
Csisér László és az ő zenekar, akik a
zenei szolgálatot, a dicsőítést vezetni
fogják. Ezt akkor mondjuk el, hogy
pontosan hányadik-án is lesz, hogyha ha
a hallgatók közül valaki eljönne, akár
nem feltétlenül udvarhelyről, akkor
tudja, hogy igen. Ebben az esztendőben
2025-ben június 18-án, szerdán este 8
órától lesz a fókuszpont, egy két órás
program.
Emlékszem, amikor készültünk erre a
fókuszpontra, én én nagyon intenzíven
megpróbáltam beleásni magam, hogy mi is
a lényege a fókuszpontnak. Meg bevallom
őszintén, az eukarisztiának a lényegét
sem értettem. Nem, nem mintogyha most
tudnám, mert egy misztérium valahol,
aminek végtelen a mélysége, de az, hogy
kiálljak melléd és beszéljek erről,
ahhoz kevésnek éreztem magam is a
tudásom. Úgyhogy én nekifogtam és és
elkezdtem ezzel kapcsolatban
dokumentálódni. És két dolog volt, ami
ami a fókuszponttal kapcsolatban mélyen
megérintett, és amit úgy, amiről egy
kicsit beszélgetnék veled. Az egyik az,
hogy a a neve, hogy miért is a
fókuszpont, hogy az eukarisztia, miért
is kell a fókuszunk középpontja legyen,
egyáltalán miért is létezik eukarisztia.
Ez más egyházaknál kiüti a biztosítékot,
hogy létezik a katolikusoknál
eukarisztia.
Viszont ezzel kapcsolatban megértettem
egy dolgot. Egyrészt az, hogy fizikailag
ez a
kenyér megjelenik és
naponta tényleg magunkhoz tudjuk venni,
vagy akár hetente, vagy akár több
havonta. Ez mégis csak visszakapcsolódik
ahhoz az előző témánkhoz, hogy
praktikus, hogy hogy nem egy elméleti
dolog, hanem valami praktikus, ami
emlékeztet arra, hogy mi is
húsvéremberek vagyunk, és testünk van,
és testi problémáink is vannak,
és tehát, hogy hogy kell foglalkoznunk
ezzel az aspektusával a világunknak. De
a másik pedig, ami ami nagyon megütötte
a gondolatomat, vagyis nagyon megütött
és és így így sokat gondolkoztam rajta
és gondolkozok folyamatosan, az hogy az
eukarisztia számomra olyan, mint egy
tökéletes memória, egy
tökéletes visszaemlékezés.
És akkor elkezdtem ezen gondolkozni,
hogy mire kell visszaemlékezzünk, mert
vannak dolgok, amik mélyen összekötnek
minket, de amiatt, mert nem beszélünk
róla, emiatt emiatt hajlamosak vagyunk
elfelejteni, hogy mi az, ami minket
összeköt.
És azt látom, hogy egy közösséget, egy
családot, egy nemzetet is az önként
vállalt szenvedés az, ami összeköt. A az
önként vállalt szenvedés az, hogy
közösen áldozatot vállalunk. Tehát az
áldozatvállalás az, ami összeköt minket,
de az áldozat az egy kellemetlen dolog,
amit önként vállalunk egy magasabb jónak
az érdekébe. A az a közösség, amelyik
nem képes önként felelősséget vállalni,
vagyis hogy áldozatot vállalni
egymásért, az szét fog szét fog
töredezni, az szét fog
szét fog bomlani. És mi mi ahogy egy
alma is, hogyha magára hagyjuk, hogy a
fától eltávolodik a forrásától, abban a
pillanatban elkezd felbomlani és
és az eukarisztia számomra legalábbis az
egy olyan
emlékezet, ami amire vissza kell
emlékezzek, hogy
egyrészt mi is az önként vállalt
szenvedésnek a mély mély
bölcsessége. És a másik pedig egy
emlékezet arra is, hogy ki vagyok én
valójában, mert én az a személy vagyok,
aki képes önként áldozatot vállalni.
És hogyha ez tényleg így van, hogy az
önként vállalt áldozatnak a
a hatása az a a az ez egy áldás, az egy
az a megváltás, akkor felv feltevődik
bennem a kérdés, hogy ha én képes vagyok
áldozatot vállalni önként és áldás
leszek a környezetem számára, akkor
mekkora a legnagyobb áldozat, amit
hozhatok? Ez az egyik. És a másik pedig
az, hogy mekkora lehet a legnagyobb
áldás, amivel az életemmel szolgálhatok
a környezetem fele, mert valójában ennél
izgalmasabb dolog nincs ennél a
kérdésnél, hogy mit kell feláldozzak
magamból, és hogy mekkora lesz ennek a a
a ez egy kaland. Ez egy kaland. Tehát
amikor elkezdem feláldozni a
kényelmemet, a az aroganciámat, a
a kévágyat bennem, a mindenféle
surmóságot, ami amúgy bennem is megvan,
és azt látom, hogy ezt át lehet váltani
arra, hogy a közösség számára egy áldás
legyen, akkor felmerül a kérdés, hogy
rendben, akkor mi legyen a következő? És
és nyilván ez az imának a a a folyama,
hogy hogy ez ahhoz, hogy megtudjam, mit
kell feláldozzak magamból, ahhoz az
valójában ez egy ima, leülök az ágyam
szédére és megkérdezem, hogy Istenem,
mit kell feláldozzak most magamból
legközelebb? Mi az a három stupid dolog,
amit csinálok az életemben? És és
holnaptól jó lenne, hogyha abbahagynám,
és egyből tudom, hogy mi lesz az. Szóval
visszatérve az eukarisztiára, hogy
számomra ez a tökéletes emlékezés, hogy
olyan, mint a céltáblának a kellős
közepe, ami és ezért is fókuszpont a
neve, hogy visszaemlékszünk arra, hogy
mi az, ami minket összetart valójában a
legmélyén, mi az, ami által létezik
bármi is. Ezt így is
megfogalmazhatnám. És a másik pedig az,
hogy ki vagyok én. visszaemlékezni az én
feladatomra, hogy mi mi az én
felelősségem ebbe, hogyha tényleg látom
az önként vállalt áldozatnak a csodáját,
akkor akkor nekem mi a feladatom ebbe?
Visszaemlékezni arra, hogy én képes
vagyok ezt megtenni. És
akkor erről szól számomra a fókuszpont,
hogy hogy odafókuszálunk és az Úr napja
erről szól.
Erről mi a van-e van-e valamilyen
gondolatod ezzel kapcsolatban?
Megpróbáltam összefoglalni, hogy ez
számomra az az egyik legizgalmasabb
kérdés, ami a fókuszponttal kapcsolatban
felmerült. Olyan szépen
megfogalmazt a simmán bekerülhet a
katolikus egyháznak a
tanításába ez a
világos gondolatmenet.
Nekem az jut eszembe, hogy az utolsó
vacsora minden szentmisének és minden
olyan imádságnak, ahol az oltári
szentség középpontban van, a mintája, az
egy jól megszervezett alkalom volt. Egy
húsvéti vacsora volt, amire Jézus
összehívta őket.
az Egyiptomból való szabadulást
ünnepelték, és mondhatjuk
elvonatkoztatva, hogy a bűn
szolgaságából való szabadulásnak lett a
az emléke az eukarisztia, vagy az
eukarisztikus alkalom. Aztán Jézus
megmosta a tanítványainak a lábát,
amiről szintén lehetne elmélkedni, de
hogy volt egy
előkészítő mozzanat,
egy ilyen ritus, hogy Jézus lehajolt,
persze Péter
tiltakozott, de aztán végül
megértette, hogy erre az alázatos
gesztusra szüksége van Péternek is, hogy
elfogadja, hogy Jézus őt meg akarja
tisztítani először
testileg.
Aztán Jézus, amit ott elmondott,
megtörve a kenyeret, a tanítványok nem
értették még, mi az, hogy megtöri a
kenyeret, és azt mondja, hogy ez az én
testem. De megértik akkor, amikor ez
valóságosan egy napra rá meg is
történik, amikor megtöri az ő testét
értük, s amikor az a vér mossa le az ő
lelküknek a bűneit, a víz, a port a
lábukról, a testükről, de Jézusnak a
vére lemossa az ő bűneiket és minden
embernek a bűnét, ami a a kereszten
a Jézusnak a sebeiből forrásozott.
Ott azt gondolom, hogy a a fókuszpontnak
is és minden olyan liturgiának, ahol a
középpontjába az eukarisztia áll, ezt
kell mintáznia. Tehát mi amikor
odamegyünk, akkor
letérdelünk, meghajtjuk a a térdeinket,
hogy
mondjam,
megalázkodunk és beismerjük azt, hogy az
életünknek az értelme Istennél van, hogy
nem mi birtokoljuk egy nagyobb előtt. És
ez a az imádatnak a jele. És boldog, aki
meg tudja ezt tenni.
hogy hogy le tud térdepelni az
eukarisztia előtt, és hogy ezt a
hétköznapokban is majd tettekre kell
váltsuk, hogy a hétköznapokban is így
kell éljünk, mint ahogy az asztalnál
tettük, alázatosan, beismerve a
bűneinket, egymásnak
megbocsátva és vennünk kell, mert Jézus
azt mondja, aki eszi az én testemet és
isza az én véremet, annak örök élete
van. És mi ebbe hiszünk, ezért a
fókuszpont valahogy minket el kell
vezessen a szentmisére.
Közelebb kell, nem csak egy olyan
rendezvény, nem egy rendezvény kell
legyen, ahol nagyon jól érezzük magunkat
és dicsőítjük az énekekkel az Urat,
hanem a fókuszpont az el kell vezessen a
másnapi ünnepre, az oltári szentség
ünnepére, és el kell vigyen minket kézen
fogva vasárnapról, vasárnapra a
testvérekkel együtt a kenyértörésnek a
közösségébe. Ezért a keresztény
katolikus ember számára nem egy
lehetőség a vasárnapnak a megünneplése,
nem egy opció, hanem kötelező a
vasárnapi szentmise.
Az egyik, amit mi ettél, ez a
térdhajtás, emlékszem, hogy hogy
erőteljesen feljött bennem is, hogy hogy
térdeljünk le, mert felmerült a kérdés,
hogy akkor álljunk vagy üljünk, vagy
vagy hogyan rendeződjünk el abból a
patkóakú Márton áron téren. És és
erőteljesen feljött bennem, hogy hogy le
kell térdeljünk. Pont amiatt, mert volt
az a kép, v a kép, amikor Mózes az égő
csipke bokor előtt leveti a saruját, és
letérdel. és a a az ember helye a szent
előtt az ad térdén van. És hogy ezt de
úgy úgy nehéz volt elképzelni, hogy azon
a kemény
macskaköves járdán, hogy hogyan fognak
letérdelni az emberek, meg lesznek
idősebbek is, lesznek fiatalok is, de
úgy na volt bennem egy izgalom. És
teljesen megdöbbentő volt számomra, hogy
azt a a 20-30 percet, amit amíg a
szentség imádás tartott, mindenki
letérdelt, és olyan megható volt látni,
hogy sokszor olyan emberek, tehát hogy
utólag látom felvételeken, mert ott a a
színpadnál azért nem láttam annyi
embert.
De hogy hogy voltak idősebbek is,
akiknek igazán nehezére esett
letérdelni, és minden indokuk meglett
volna, hogy ne térdeljenek le. És és
nagyon felemelő volt számomra látni ezt
ezt az elcsendesedés, ezt a a a méltó
helyünket megkapni a térdünk. Még talán
egy kicsit arról
beszélnék a fókuszponttal kapcsolatban,
hogy megszervezni ezt először nagyon sok
harccal járt is, belső harccal is.
Emlékszem, az egyik gondolatunk az volt,
hogy hogy honnan lesz erre pénz, mekkora
legyen a a maga a rendezvény, hogy
merjünk-e nagy lettévét bérelni, vagy
csak elégedjünk meg egy kicsikével, és
hogy mennyi virág legyen rajta, és hogy
legyen-e ennek professzionális média
promója és háttere. És végül is
mindegyiknél úgy döntöttünk, hogy allén
belemegyünk, és és legyen ez egy egy
szép rendezvény. Legyen ez egy olyan
olyan, amire büszkék tudunk lenni,
emlékszem a virágból is, amennyit csak
lehetett kiraktunk. És tényleg Krisztus
ezt élemni.
Úgyhogy és nagyon szép volt
megtapasztalni azt, hogy bár mindenből a
legjobbat próbáltuk odaadni, és és
tényleg a költségei is magasak voltak,
mégis adományból pont annyi gyűlt össze,
hogy fed fedezte ezt a a az egész
alkalmat, és még egy kicsi, pont úgy,
mint a kenyérszaporításnál, hogy hogy
nemcsak, hogy mindenki jól lakott, hanem
még maradt a a kenyér szaporítás után.
Úgyhogy számomra ez egy hihetetlen
élmény volt újra és újra megtapasztalni,
hogy hogy tényleg, hogyha valami jó
dolognak fogunk neki, akkor a a tényleg
a föld alól is előbújnak emberek, hogy
jöjjenek és
segítsenek. Ez neked milyen volt
megtapasztalni?
Számomra ez Istenérv. Én 20 éve vagyok
pap, és azt tapasztaltam, hogy ha
Istennek az ügyében
járok, akkor a minimum az, hogy
meglesznek az
anyagiak, hogy nem volt olyan program,
amit nem tudtunk megszervezni azért,
mert nem volt pénz rá. Itt is az volt,
hogy erre a rendezvényre nem volt külön
elkülendítve összeg, de ott volt a az
embereknek a a zsebében, és a szívébe a
vágy, amikor beszéltem róla, akkor
megnyílt és
adakoztak és
tudod, Rómára visszatérve, ha valaki
turistaként megy, akkor megcsodálja a
templomokat Rómának a szépet
és mondhatja azt, ha belép egy pápai
bazilikába, hogy hát ez
túlzás, miért kellett a mennyezetet
megaranyozni, de ha zarándokként megy
valaki, akkor ez mögött azt látja, hogy
Istennek mindig a legszebb, a legjobb
járt. És a szegény ember is áldozatot
hozott azért, hogy bár ő viskóba vagy
kis házikóba egy szobába, vagy éppen az
utcán lakik, de Istennek a háza legyen
gyönyörű, legyen a
legszebb. És
itt is a fókuszponton is az volt,
hoztunk egy döntést. Istennek a
legszebb, a legjobb jár.
És nem a költségeit néztük, és
valóban megadta az Úr. Sőt,
gyermekkoromban emlékszem, hogy kenyeret
sütöttünk édesanyámmal, és a végén
mindig egy kicsit megtartottunk belőle,
ami a kovász lett. Itt is úgy volt, hogy
mindent mindent kifizettünk, és a végén
egy pár a lej, egy kicsi
összegadt. Ezzel is az Úr jelezte azt,
hogy meg fogom szaporítani, hogy lesz az
idénre is. És az idén már már nem kérdés
az, hogy hogy akkor meglesznek-e hozzá
az anyagiak. Igen. Visszatérve erre,
amit amit mondtál, hogy hogy Istennek a
legjobb jár. hogy én én én amikor ezen
gondolkoztam, az jutott eszembe, hogy
tényleg, hogyha most a egy stradivári
hegedűt képzelek el, ki kell játszon a
strádivári hegedűn egy szegény gyermek,
aki éppen tanul
tanul hegedülni, vagy pedig egy
virtuóhoz hegedűs, aki aki egész
életében ezt gyakorolta, és meg tudja
szólaltatni ezt a ezt a hegedűt. És ez
egy nagyon fontos kérdés, mert sokszor
az együttérzés bennünk elvakít.
Tehát, hogy van az a az evangéliumi
rész, amikor Mária jön megmosni Jézusnak
a lábát, és Mária Magdolna, és és Júdás
megjegyzi, hogy hát ez el lehetett volna
adni ezt a drága
drága olajat, és hány szegény
hány szegényen lehetett volna segíteni.
És erre Jézus megszólal, hogy bár ez
igaz, szegények mindig lesznek, és én
most itt vagyok. Úgyhogy ennek itt van a
helye ennek a a az imádatnak. És ez egy
nagyon nagyon mély alapelvre irányít
számomra, hogy az imádat mindig
fontosabb, mint az együttérzés, mert
tényleg az van, hogy vannak dolgok,
amelyek szentek, és az a szent dolgoknak
meg kell adni a méltó környezetét. Tehát
egy pólóra vagy egy eldobható dologra
azért mégsem festünk szentképet.
hanem a szentkép valami olyan dologra
kell kerüljön, ami ami értékes anyag,
ami megmarad, mert mert problematikus.
Mi történik akkor, hogyha már kikopik,
akkor akkor eldobjuk, nem tudom a a
szentképet, mi történik vele,
feldarabolják, elégetik. Szóval a maga a
szimbóluma is ilyen szempontból
problémás. Szóval visszatérve én azt
látom, hogy hogy ki kell aranyserleget
használjon egy milliárdos, aki
megengedheti magának, kinek kell legyen
arany serlege? És én teljes nyugalom van
bennem, akkor legyen a Vatikánnál, ahol
Istennek van felajánlva ez az
aranyserleg, mint inkább egy milliárdos
házába, és hogy ha már egyáltalán
létezik aranyserleg, felverül a kérdés,
akkor egyáltalán kellenek-e
aranyserlegek a világban? És ez egy egy
másik filozófiai kérdés. Kellenek-e
olyan dolgok, amelyek értékesek a
világban, vagy hogy csak azért, mert
léteznek szegények, minden dolgot
alacsonyítsunk le arra a hétköznapi
szintre, ami ami már unalmas, ami már
tömegre gyártott és olcsó. És bizonyos
szempontból ide kerülünk megint Carlónak
a gondolatához, hogy hogy másolatok
akarunk lenni, egy hangúságra akarunk
törekedni, vagy pedig keressük azt a
kincset magunkban, ami ami amire elhív
minket Isten, és ami által széppé
válhatunk, különlegessé válhatunk, és
hogy kellenek a szép dolgok az
életünkben, kell törekedjünk arra, hogy
az átlagot felülmúljuk, saját magunk
átlagát felülmúljuk.
Úgyhogy visszatérve ehhez az egész
gondolatmenethez, én azt látom, hogy
kell törekedjünk arra, hogy képesek
legyünk kincseket termelni, és a
kincseket pedig a megfelelő helyre
tenni, mert a kincseknek megvan a
megfelelő helye. És a megfelelő helye
számomra jó helyen van a Vatikánban, jó
helyen van a templomba, jó helyen van
ott, ahol felajánljuk a legmagasabbnak.
Igen.
Jól van, jól van. Köszönöm akkor, hogy
körbejárhattuk ezt a témát is. Igazából
még csak egy dologról szeretnék veled
beszélni. 20 éve szolgálsz papként, és
az egyik szívügyed az a
fiatalság. Egy kicsit mesélnél arról,
hogy mit milyen kezdeményezésekbe fogtál
az elmúlt évtizedbe? Kicsit mesélnél a
FIFről például, mi a küldetése
és és merre tart?
Gyergyó Szentmiklóson szolgáltam
először, és ott a egy
nagyon szívemhez közelálló előjárom volt
plébános. Én segédlelkész voltam. Rám
bízta az
ifjúságot és szerzetes nővérek
segítettek abba a munkába. Sokat
tanultam tőlük a fiataloktól.
Megkedveltem a lelkipásztori munkának
ezt a területét. Hány éves voltál akkor?
25 éves voltam, akkor szenteltek pappá.
Három esztendőt szolgáltam ott.
Aztán egyszer egészen váratlanul a
püspököm felajánlotta, hogy Rómába
mehetek
tanulni. És
én dönthettem el, hogy mit
tanuljak. Lelkipásztorkodásant
választottam, vagyis
gyakorlatib dolgokat, hogyan kell egy
közösséget vezetni.
És ahogy hazatértem Rómából, akkor az
egész egyház megyének az ifjúságát rám
bízta a az érsek.
És ennek a szervezetnek, az ifjúsági
lelkészségnek a vezetését,
munkacsoportszervezését. Hát évek
kellettek,
míg
tapasztalatból így, vagyis amíg
tapasztalatot szereztem, csapatot
építettem, nagyon szépen elkezdett
növekedni ez a szervezet. megújítottuk a
Csíksomjői ifjúsági találkozót, ami egy
nyári nagy tábor volt, egy Erdély
ifjúságának szóló
program, és ami egy hétvégés alkalom
volt, de mi egy ötnapos rendezvényi
növeltük. Ott szükség volt
önkéntesekre, fiatalokra, és ott
értettem meg, hogy először képeznünk
kell vezetőket.
Így született meg 10 évvel ezelőtt a
teljes szívvel ifjúsági vezetőképző, ami
azóta is működik, és most már több 100
fiatal képződött itt. Az volt a célunk,
hogy a különböző
plébániáknak legyenek szakképzett
fiataljai, akik fiatalként szolgálnak
más fiatalokat.
És aztán Isten megáldotta anyagilag is
ezt a
szervezetet, hogy a magyar kormánynak a
támogatásából egy ifjúsági házat
építettünk
Szelterfdőn, ahol
tulajdonképpen a tevékenységeit
folytatja most képzéseit a az ifjúsági
lelkészség, és továbbra is
működik a Csíkső ifjúsági találkozót és
sok más rendezvényt is szervezés én
olyan hálás vagyok a jó Istennek, hogy
ezen a területen
működhettem a az én ifjúsági
lelkészségem alatt, hogy mondjam, a
naposabb oldalát
mutatta meg az egyházamnak a fiatalokat,
akiktől mindig tanulhattam, mindig
vérfrissesség volt. ö a közöttük voltam,
akkor éreztem a pezsgését a az életnek,
és így szolgálok itt is a kis Szenterész
plébánián is, hogy különleges hangsúly
van az ifjúságon.
Azt is tudni kell, hogy a fiatalok nem
egyik pillanatról a másikra lesznek,
hanem nekünk, mint
közösségvezetőknek, a gyermekeknek,
a
gyermekeknek való programszervezéssel
kell kezdeni. A hitoktatást, a plébánia
hittanokat köz komolyan kell venni, és
így tud majd ifjúsági csoport lenni. É
istennek hálami plébániánkon
három
ö ifjúsági csoport is van,
úgyhogy külön foglalkozunk
vagy
fiatalokkal együtt
bérmákozási felkész bérmákozásra
készítünk fel fiatalokat és az is egy
nagy kihívás ma 18 éveseknek az
egyháznak a
tanítását a a szentségi
életet
így vagy ebbe segíteni őket, az
egyháznak a tanítását megismertetni
velük, hogy
visszataláljanak a középponthoz, az Úr
Jézushoz. Barni, köszönöm szépen, hogy
itt voltál. Azt hiszem, hogy ez egy
tartalmas beszélgetés volt, és ez egy jó
pont abbahagyni. Hálás vagyok neked
ezekért a beszélgetésekért, amit olyan
sokan megtekintenek. És hálás vagyok
azoknak a világiaknak, az én
testvéreimnek, akik nem papként,
hanem
világiként érik a hitüket, szolgálnak
mások
felé. Ettől lesz élővé egy közösség,
hogy minél
többen tartunk ugyanazon cél felé, Isten
felé.
Ámen. Köszönöm szépen, hogy itt voltál.
Bar
szeretettel Istennek legyen hála. Ha
tetszett ez a műsor, akkor iratkozz fel
kérlek a csatornánkra. Ezzel tudsz
támogatni minket. Köszönjük a Week kávé
közösségnek a jó kávéért, az ötvös
udvarnak a helyért, valamint a
bizalomtőkének a támogatásért.
Nélkületek nem jöhetett volna ez létre.